Democrats this morning are gearing up
for the last day of their convention in
his speech last night President Obama
said Donald Trump will not win the White
House with a campaign based on fear he's
selling the American people short we're
not a fragile people they're not a
frightful people our power doesn't come
from some self-declared Savior promising
that he alone can restore order as long
as we do things his way we don't look to
be ruled Dan Pfeiffer and Jon Favreau
know President Obama's messages well Dan
as a former senior advisor to the
president John served as his director of
speechwriting he helped with the
president's address last night together
they now hosts a podcast called keeping
it 1600 good morning good morning guys
it's a good title
yeah the 1600 is a gift that keeps on
giving John the president brought you
back to help on this speech tonight what
goes into the construction of this
speech what was that what were you
trying to convey I mean I think a couple
weeks ago I know he met with Cody Keenan
they both sort of drafted most of the
speech together and you know he had
three things he wanted to do he wanted
to you know make sure that he showed his
support for Hillary Clinton and talked
about what it was like working with her
what it was like personally knowing her
why she's ready to be commander-in-chief
and then you know he also wanted to take
on Trump ISM more than just Trump but
sort of trumps whole philosophy and and
also the speech was a bookend to 2004
his first convention speech which was
all about patriotism and American values
basically you know everything in that
2004 speech you know Donald Trump
doesn't represent the past he is not
mentioned Donald Trump whenever he's
speaking he's not mentioned by name and
even saying I see no need to but last
night he did but what was the thinking
behind that I think it was just the more
you start saying like the other opponent
the other guy everyone knows that so
then let's assume let's assume for a
moment you head of communications or
Hillary Clinton what do you have to do
tonight because you've seen a big night
last night and even a big night with
Michelle Obama before that well you
haven't
I think the maze the test I think
Hillary Clinton's audience tonight is
undecided voters but it's not voters who
are undecided about who to vote for Fitz
we were undecided whether to vote unique
she needs people to be as fired up for
her as she as they were for Brock Obama
to stand in line for hours on election
day or an early vote stations to vote
and because at the end of the day the
math is very simple for a Democrat it's
zero people who voted for Mitt Romney
vote for Hillary Clinton but most people
who go to Barack Obama though she still
wins a large election so it's about
raising the stakes to get people a
reason to go through because 153 to 47%
against Mitt Romney it's fair to say
only she can do that all these other
people can't do they can help but she
has to close the deal
let's keep John Doe - I mean what some
of the phrasing in there I mean this was
about when he said that Donald Trump is
a home grown demagogue and placed him in
the same sentence as fascist communist
and jihadis there must have been a
debate about that line then what do you
think the league does the legacy he
wants to leave and how much is it about
stumping for Hillary Clinton to continue
that legacy I thought one of the most
interesting things about this speech
last night is this is his last major
speech he could have spent he's on
estates for 44 minutes he could have
spent 20 minutes talking about himself
going through all of his accomplishments
but instead he spent just the opening of
the speech talking about what he
accomplished if it the rest of it
stumping for Hillary Clinton and against
Donald Trump and the reason for that is
to actually
cement his legacy it's a critically
important pillar footing away is he
raring to go because he has a special
animus about Trump because he thinks
there are two American views and he
doesn't and he's repelled by Trump you
it's not personal about Trump a lot of
people ask that question cuz he raised
the birth certificates not that he's
gonna thick skin people said horrible
things about him he he's a deeply
disturbed by Trump's vision of American
the thing that I've always think the
president is what makes him the most mad
is when someone in a position of power
Kicks down at those who aren't in power
so whether it's Muslims and the
immigrants women when he sees that he
takes upon himself to go out there and
fight for them and I think that's why
he's you can feel the passion and what
he has said about Trump's views and how
he's framed this election and we
certainly felt his passion to less and I
was wondering how much of it was
influenced by Michelle Obama there were
reports that he was up at 3 o'clock
reading and she read and she tweeted
this that's my man your choose dignity
and grace reminds us what real
leadership looks like I'm always proud
of our POTUS do you think there's
competition between the two right for
him what is his skill as a lord I think
his skill is storytelling and not just
like individual anecdotes but every
speech from beginning to end the hello
story is not a collection of applause
line and what was his story last night
so it was it was a story about America
what American values really are
how do you really define patriotism you
know what it means to be an American he
does a good aspiration then he doesn't
get aspiration dan the other paragraph
to Gail and I were talking about this
nobody else did this and we didn't think
talked about what we didn't see in
Cleveland last night he said what we saw
wasn't particularly Republican and it
sure wasn't conservative it was a deeply
pessimistic vision for the country I
know you because I covered the White
House in terms of messaging a convention
it was a stark contrast between these
two conventions it absolutely was the I
thought was interesting in the paragraph
five minutes the president made a very
specific outreach to those Republicans
those conservatives who are very
uncomfortable Trump but it did that to
you right but I have not yet decided
that they're gonna Rico they may write
someone in or stay home and try to
create a permission structure for them
to come forward in support Hillary
because Donald Trump does have the right
temperament experience to be President
turnout is a huge issue in this election
Bay because the relative unpopularity of
both candidates going in right
absolutely this is if if we have turnout
somewhat of 2012
Hillary Clinton will win this election
if you win by a larger margin that Brock
Obama if we dull Donald Trump to be
president all comes down to people say
who votes in a way congratulations on
keeping it real 1600 Thank You Dan may
offer my congratulations to your
upcoming marriage thank you got
excellent and John's too
I just saw his fiancee back safe yours
is as nice as she